Kylie Jenner reportedly donates 1  million dollars to Australia's relief  effort the 22 year old Beauty moguls  generous aid comes after she was dragged  online for posting a snap of her mink  fur Louie Vuitton slippers to her  Instagram story directly after posting  about the death of animals in  Australia's devastating fires a reported  half a billion animals have died in the  fires so far Kylie isn't the only  kardashian-jenner combating backlash  over the devastating wildfires both  Kylie's sisters Kendall and Kim have  been called out by internet trolls for  their assumed lack of efforts it was  really tough for me Kim was quick to  clap back at everyone who accused her of  not using her wealth and platform to  help combat the crisis tweeting in part  nothing gets me more heated than to see  people think they know what we donated -  and to think we have to publicize  everything I just think is really wrong  and I wanted to get that message out  there Amen sister  [Music]